This is Jocko podcast number 20 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good evening.
Echo Jack. Yes. We'll go again. Yeah,
it's that after it life two video rolling and one's rolling.
But I did train on mother's Day. Yeah, I wasn't,
I didn't drink no specifically because it was one of those. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A lot of people do it. They give it to Sarah. Yeah. A lot of people did that.
She even said go train. I'm going to go to Kohl's. Yeah, it was done.
Where was your fucking stupid ass? No, she didn't go to Kohl's,
I guess getting gum.
No, I'm the kind where mentally where if I'm like, okay,
I'm going to accept it that I that am not going to go to. Yeah,
I probably shouldn't have fine. But I did. Hey man, that's your shit.
I probably should've, but I got after it.
It's all good. I think ultimately, you know, if that's cool,
if that's cool and that's cool either as coolers to not. Yeah,
I don't know about that. All right. Camera Two's rolling. Audio is rolling.
Confirmed everything and no one knows anything that I know.
So it's gonna, right? Yeah. You don't wanna be that guy. Don't be that guy.
Um, is that clicking, going to show up on the uh,
recording you think it, I don't know. Maybe a little bit.
You've been hammering that thing. I know. The thing is I always do it
of course.
Oh, you like talking [inaudible] nerve it,
you know how I say I like to doodle. That helps. Oh, sorry.
Your Taco with the save and can man,
I don't know if I say it because you are doing it for a period of time.
Your range. Yeah, you could say that.
Go ahead and roll camera two if you'd be willing. Enabled.
So you're like,
you're like the talent and the assistant director and that's Kinda cool.
You were on that I was thinking of while you were talking of like making some
adjustments that just, I said better, not achievable. Yeah,
I don't, I don't,
I don't go to your house and grab your gun and start flying it. Oh No,
you don't in there.
So you understand if there's any special leading who should do to this?
No. Indicate what it is, you know, give them the heads up.
This is all Q and. A. We're going more or less an extension.
Straight to Q. And. A. All right, let's do it. Alright. Rolling.
One and two's rolling.
Global confirmed double phone on and placed in an annoying vibration,
whatever year that was. Yours vibrating. No, it wasn't. Well,
it wasn't popping up on the screen. And since I've now said that like,
oh, now when I hear it, I'm like, I'm like, you really hear it?
Oh yeah. It's like the, it's like the whole monkey thing. Hey,
that's my bad fuck. I thought it was yours the whole time. No,
I was about to take some extreme dis ownership on the, on.